[Music]
yeah
hey guys
how's it going
so this will be my first ever official
June livestream so I hope everyone can
hear me tell me how am i sounding can
you hear me
pretty good hear my voice I know there's
somewhat of a delay so I'm gonna wait
for you guys to respond Hey hey everyone
bless the maker and his water indeed yep
so everyone can hear me okay cool cool
at least I think I think telling me that
you can hear me okay awesome awesome
awesome awesome awesome see that that
delay is like so intense it's like oh my
god can they can they not so excellent
excellent excellent I am so glad that
everyone is here well today we're doing
a livestream for dune which I've never
done a livestream exclusively to talk
about dune but usually after I finish
one of my big ultimate guide episodes
what I will do is I'll do a dune talk
video and I thought this is the perfect
occasion to do it live because I have so
many extra notes for heretics because
it's a very most multi-faceted story
there's a lot going on and if you did
see the heretics of dune video already
then you can tell like it's jumping
between planets between characters and
plots there's a lot going on
it's quite different from the other
novels in that way most of them are
exclusively on dune or they just jump
between one or two places maybe there's
a little bit you know one in Children of
Dune there's a little bit on SaLuSa
secondo sigh believe yes elusive is it
SaLuSa the planet of house Kirino I'm
pretty sure it's elusive secondo yet is
there's a little bit there on but here
it's like gamoo there's Rakus there's
laylax
it's all over the place so and so here I
wanted to answer a couple of the
questions that I was getting after I
uploaded the video because I always
you want to make sure that everything is
clear there's a lot going on so I get
why people miss certain elements of the
story because it's very easy to and
Frank Herbert does have that kind of
writing style where it's like you had
kind of have to really focus on what
he's saying or notes you're not gonna
get it one big question that a lot of
people were asking and I was glad that
they were asking this question because I
really wanted to answer it they were
saying when Leto said to the Vinick
Jesuit when node-red goes in there and
she reads they when you and she
remembers she recalls his words he says
they must call me chaton emperor of
Gehenna the wheel must turn on and on
along the golden path it's something
like that I don't have the exact quote
pulled up but it's something like that
when I am gone they must call me shite
an emperor of Gehenna now that is
there's two biblical references here and
for Herbert loves his public alike rfl
but these these references are more
direct than Arif L so let's start with
the first one soshite an a lot of you
wondered what why are they calling him
shite and why is the god of the desert
now being referred to as Shaytan well in
the Hebrew language Shaytan was a word
was the word for accuse or accuser or
the enemy the opponent so essentially
Shaytan is Satan the devil Lucifer at
the enemy the great enemy not Latos
great enemy but the devil the enemy in
the Bible so that's what that's
essentially what Shaytan is so he says
you must call me Shaytan Emperor of
Gehenna Gehenna is the second biblical
reference no Gehenna was a place in the
valley and a valley in Jerusalem and it
was a place where these kings would
sacrifice their children and so it was a
cursed place a condemned place so what
the god of her is saying here
essentially is they must call me the
devil essentially emperor of the
condemned a ruler of a curse - condemned
people a cursed condemned place it goes
back to the golden path it all goes back
to the golden path and late to his
vision for the future and late to his
vision for himself he understood that
people had to hate him if the golden
path was to work essentially he had to
be viewed by history as this kind of
evil satanic figure and it's very
interesting in heretics of doom where
when she Anna when they hear she ona the
priest here she ought to call him shy
can and they kind of scoff at it they're
like oh my gosh she's calling him
Shaytan because that kid that carries
significant connotations and ultimately
the priesthood is is an interesting
concept because ultimately the god
Emperor would be against the priesthood
it like the priesthood by the very
nature work in opposition to the golden
path because they are promoting this
idea that yes Leto was a god yes he is
divine and you've got Gianna who comes
in and kind of subverts that it which is
very interesting so and they are met
with this very unique kind of conflict
between Gianna and these kind of
heretical things that she is saying and
her also being able to control these
auras to be able to come to commune with
their God in a way that they can't so
yeah I mean I'm reading something you
see you guys have stuff so yeah so yeah
so it Emperor of Gehenna it goes back to
how Leto needs to be viewed in history
in order for people to move on and in
order for people to look back and always
fear that kind of ruler and always fear
that kind of leader right because Frick
bill the whole crux of this story is
that Frank Herbert wants us to see
through our charismatic leaders that was
the ultimate lesson of the golden path
Leto said to manao
I think in God and proved to him that I
am a predator I need to be viewed as a
predator and that's exactly what he is
that's exactly what Shaytan is that's
what that represents emperor of Gehenna
they must call me Shaytan
gianna and it's such a it's such a Frank
Herbert it's just such a such a good he
just said he just has such a good way of
representing the long view of history of
showing us how how over time
really history creates its own truth
right it doesn't it doesn't really
matter what actually happened it matters
how history interprets that way back in
Children of Dune later says that the the
history of this night will far surpass
what actually happened here but the
memory of it the memory of it is what
really matters
thank you so much Marvin Martin for your
super chat you said if Herbert had
finished the books how do you think it
might have ended what would be different
well uh uh it's really hard to say and
I'll tell you what Marvin Marvin thank
you so much for that super shot but I
want to wait until I put out my ultimate
guide to chapter house soon before I
make all of my comments on the end of
the series and how I think that it would
have ended versus the Brian Herbert
stuff because I do think there would
have been some pretty big divergences
there but I want to wait until I go
through Chapter house like I've done to
all the other books and really break
everything down and really get to the
nitty gritty before I make any
conclusions and put anything out there
in the universe and definitively say
this is what I think would have happened
so I was so basically what I'm telling
you is I want to avoid sounding like an
idiot before and really really like
really like make sure I understand
everything before I say anything before
I say anything solid uh-huh presley
baldwin says hey there sorry that i have
not seen your content in a little while
just wondering what your favorite dooms
story is zooming out of all of the books
well i have to say that god Emperor is
probably still my favorite book out of
the six herbert books definitely
definitely definitely definitely um okay
so that was my
that's that was my answer on Leto
Emperor of Gehenna site annular of
Gehenna so does anyone have any more
questions on that a little bit before I
move on to what I wanted to talk about
next which was what's going on with the
bene Jesuits and all this stuff in
heretics of tune so has anyone have any
questions on the improv guy here nowhere
is that pretty cut and dry because it's
pretty straightforward once you get the
references well you once you understand
what he's referring to it's pretty it's
pretty obvious san Barrios do I follow
josh brolin on instagram I don't have an
Instagram account but I did see that
video of him on Arrakis it was pretty
cool there on Arrakis now they're
filming and it's really freaking awesome
should the Golden Path be implemented in
our world um I don't know I see that's
such a hard question because I am not
the one to judge because I am not late
to the second I don't have by the way
thank you for your super chat I don't I
can't look into history I can't look
into the I can't look into humanity's
past and looking to humanity's future to
see it for myself so I don't know what's
necessary say what's great about Leto is
that he could look into the future in
the past with better access than anyone
else so he really knew what was
necessary know if I became the super
quiz that's header like of the universe
and I find I found myself looking into
the future and I found the necessary
steps to take and I was willing to do it
then I guess like we'd have to create
our own golden path right it has to fit
our own world so see we could use a
golden path essentially as what I'm
trying to say maybe not necessarily the
one that's in the Dune universe ok so ah
more super chats thank you guys you're
so generous
Marvin Martin thank you again part of
the Golden Path was stagnation leading
to extinction yet human nature and some
cultures have been around since day one
and we're still kicking I'm so confused
um well you know cultures evolve
cultures definitely evolve I mean even
even though we do have cultures that
have been around for thousands of years
I would argue that the vast majority of
them aren't
same as they were even like a thousand
years ago I mean it's very difficult to
maintain that exact the same thing for
that long I think right I think I think
I think it's difficult I think to see
how much cultures evolve in the long
view of history because we only have a
certain perspective of it you know what
I mean
Silla I think I think you'd be
hard-pressed to find a civilization
that's been around for thousands of
years that hasn't changed significantly
from the time of its conception to now
you know what I mean okay but great
questions Marvin Martin you're putting
me to work make me think shawn herrick
ooh I hope I'm pronouncing that right
the manner of the ravages of time state
the concept that history is written not
by the strong but by the biases of his
stories of historians that is I think
that is true I think so in in Game of
Thrones in the Song of Ice and Fire
books which I also cover a lot on this
channel George or Marion likes to
present his history through the view of
these people called maesters who are
kind of like the historian subscribes of
history and he makes a point into
demonstrating that they have their own
biases and what you're reading from them
might not necessarily be what actually
went down and I think that is a very
true thing in all of history
yeah and you see this in dune as well in
the very first book we are getting all
these like little tidbits from aerilon
about MIDI and but we're seeing it
through the eyes of Arab on so can we
really trust Irulan to give the most
accurate representations of what was
really happening in these times which is
why God Emperor is a very interesting
book because I like to think in my mind
that this book is being told it's just
being told from the perspective of what
later wrote in his in his journals so
it's interesting like okay so this God
Emperor could be the most accurate book
as far as like but yeah as far as like
how how accurate is and how reliable the
narrator is because Leto
has to be the most reliable narrator
that you could ask for right so that's
very interesting and I definitely do
agree with that concept that history is
less so written by the strong because
the strong aren't writing it down it's
the historians that are writing it down
so it's the historians that get to shape
those little those subtle little nuances
and it could be something as simple as a
little bit of wording to completely
change how someone is viewed in history
just a little bit of wording were things
a little just different and it's the
difference between a conqueror and
someone a genocide err that's not a word
genocide er is not a word but you get
what I'm saying
there's not that much difference between
like someone that conquered a kingdom
and is known by history as a great ruler
and someone that's known my history is
the general silyl maniac okay and shawn
herrick who's following up and saying
that with thank you for another super
chat that the ravages of time is a
Chinese comic about Three Kingdoms and
the era of China of China so you can say
it's telling the truest history of that
era that's very very interesting I'll
have to check that out so many super
chats guys thank you so much I was not
expecting this but does heretics slash
chapterhouse
tag count as a type of quiz let's had a
wreck or is he something fully new or
how would you can arise his awakening
okay so this is a very good question I
think tag is something new and I like I
like what you just said
Brian burn and something wild he's
something new I love her I love Frank
Herbert's quote from that interview
where he's saying what would you rather
live in a box or a universe of new
surprises and that's exactly how I
interpret tags awakening it was
something that was unexpected maybe
maybe Leto himself didn't even see this
coming
you know I mean it was something that
was unexpected something new something
that came out of just like this out of
this wild crazy universe essentially so
it's something new something that we
don't quite understand and
and I wish there was a seventh book so
that we did have a little bit more
understanding of it but yeah it's
definitely something new I don't think
he's necessarily a quiz let's have Iraq
but yeah great great question alright so
I wanted to get to something else so
Vinnie jazz right the vintage esri in
this book up to all sorts uh crazy crazy
plans within plans and it gets like if
you're not careful reading this book it
can be like wait what what are you guys
up to you what are you doing
but the Vinny Jesuit they seldom do it
they they always have layered
motivations so essentially the way I
interpret what is happening in this book
is that you have the been a Jesuit and
they are training Duncan to be
irresistible to women and they were
going to use lucilla to imprint Duncan
so the he'd be loyal to the sisterhood
and then they would use Duncan to
control Gianna is what is what I'm
seeing
they would use Duncan to control Shana
at a later point but their plans got all
shaken up in the chaos Myles tag in a
double awakening Duncan before the
imprint ation process could be
implemented and then the owner ma Trace
acted unpredictably and you know their
plans just gotta kind of got shaken up
from there so then there was also this
plan that terraza had that was to
initiate the destruction of the planet
dune so that they could the bene Jesuit
will gain control will over the spice
not a monopoly because that's layout
because the flux who would be able to
produces in their acts a little tanks
but they would gain they would gain
control over the spice as far as because
there's a bit in this book I think where
it's like the the bene Jesuit they
they're like okay clay likes to spice
but like the warm spice that's like the
real it's like a real deal stuff the
warm spices the good stuff and the
texture stuff is kind of the off-brand
essentially and it was to also dilute
the god emperor's consciousness even
further
right so the God Emperor was gone he was
divided but his mark
was still upon the universe because
pearls of his awareness existed in the
in the sands and they still moved to the
tyrants ancient beat they still
essentially did his bidding bidding so
owed trade I guess kind of was aware of
this and she figured that not old raid
but terrassa she figured that in order
to remove the Benny Jesuit from the
tyrants grip what they had to do was
dilute his control dilute his awareness
and so by destroying the planet doom
they could then gain control of the
worms themselves and they would have
time to do what they needed to do before
his multi fragmented consciousness
rebuilt itself and by that point humans
would be expanded to the point where he
no longer had control over their faith
because terrazas idea was that it wasn't
necessarily that he was predicting the
future he was creating it in a sense and
you know i don't necessarily know if
terraza was correct right because it's
like it's like okay that seems like that
was kind of late to his plan anyways
right yeah yeah he did see that that's
the thing he doesn't necessarily want
anyone to have control even him so
that's why i feel like old raid in the
end truly understood owed raid
understood more than to even to rasa
right owed rate understood that they
were really freeing the god emperor they
were freeing him from this in this
stream like they were freeing him from
from his own burden so yeah it's it's
it's very it's very very it's it's it
there's a lot of food for thought here
it's a lot to think about but i got a
super chat and i really need to answer
this six foot feet is thank you so much
for your awesome super chad you were
awesome thank you guys so much you're
always so supportive just want to say
great job on all the doing content you
are truly doing god's work well thank
you so much a the kind words are greatly
appreciated and the super chat is
greatly appreciated okay Q&A do you
think you're pandering too much to the
haters and skeptics and the cynics of
Game of Thrones series
your videos haven't been positive as of
late well you know but when it comes to
Game of Thrones it's it's a show that
I've been really disappointed by but my
last my I did my last video was
definitely positive I was talking about
Cersei and you know like I said next
week we'll be reviewing those episodes
and you know we can you know we'll be
reviewing episodes what it is if it's
good at it it's good if it's not it's
not you know I'm not I've never been a
type of person to be like I like this
one I don't like it so it's like I like
it I like it if I don't like it I don't
like it but if you're in for more
analytical Game of Thrones content it's
definitely common over these next few
weeks as the show's gonna be coming out
so I'll be analyzing everything rather
than criticizing it I guess but yeah
okay Marvin Martin what about the Pearl
in the last worm you asked yeah exactly
the pearls would eventually come back
and split again and rebuilt themselves
but by that point the idea is that
humanity would be fully separated from
Latos grasp so he'd be deluded into one
worm for a significant amount of time
but then by that point human is
humankind is really spread far he has no
further grip on the Binney gesture or
anyone so yeah so basically that he's
deluded I still enjoy the TV show yeah
what is the best quote from all the
books oh that's such a good question I
don't know that's that's such a hard one
but of course fear is the mind killer is
an iconic quote obviously there's so
many I like you were servants on to
God's not servants own just servants
from God emperor of doon because that's
taken again in heretics of doing in
Chiana says you are servants of Shaytan
not servants onto surface which is very
interesting
okay I'm so conflicted I love your
content but your voice is so soothing it
begged me to take a nap well I take that
as a compliment I take that as a
compliment JT rhymes
elio Green hand issue I'm not sure I
know what you're talking about sir
but yeah okay back back on this I have a
lot of notes form the Benny gesture than
here at 6:15 which is very interesting
okay one thing I think it's funny in
this book is that very early on it's
kind of stated that it's kind of stated
that The Sisterhood follows the orders
of the Mother Superior almost to a fault
they followed they followed the Mother
Superior almost to a fault except when
they didn't it if it's got it's kind of
a private joke that yeah yeah the sister
said yeah the sisters usually follow the
Mother Superior except when they
disagree which is very interesting
because I wonder how long this kind of
joke of heresy goes back right so it's
just something that goes back to before
the time of Jessica or was Jessica's
actions against the sisterhood something
that was kind of the catalyst for this
heretical nature and the mini Jesuit
right so we're bidding Jesuit regular
we're the mini Jesuit regularly
disobeying orders before Jessica what
did the Jessica thing set off something
and I tend to think that it was
Jessica's initial disobey Lynn having
that son that later set off this
heretical nature in the main gesture
because then you have like Miles text
mother who's like a heretic and then
you've got ode raid who does some
heretical things and you've got Shuang
you who's in open rebellion against the
goal of Project so that's very
interesting because before this point
before this book we kind of see the Bene
Jesuit is kind of like this unbendable
unbreakable structure of women that's
kind of impenetrable almost and that
Jessa was Jessica was kind of a fluke
but then in this novel it's kind of like
the walls are pulled back right and we
see that they're not they really don't
actually have it all together ins in
there
there's heresy even among them so that's
very very interesting so there is it's a
it gives you an entirely new perspective
on the bond of any Jesuit sisterhood
both of these last two books - because
you learned so much about the sister
that you really didn't know before and
their nature and and something that's
coming up in heretic I mean in Chapter
house next which is very interesting is
that the is the bene Jesuit choice
decision to utilize the trial Axew Axew
oil tanks because it's something that
initially they're disgusted by but the
honor march right trays and this the
these rough times kind of drove them to
do something that's kind of to them it's
kind of an abomination which is to you
so that's that's very interesting
something that we're gonna get into
later in in chapter house tune so the
videos what's interesting about them
though is of the prime guy they're
pragmatic they're constantly evolving
they're always willing to evolve and
that's how they have survived so long
that's how they survived through the
time of moody Eve and some survived
through the time of the tyroid and
survived through the famine times it's
their pragmatism their willingness to
change and evolve and move on mmm-hmm
all right I'm just reading you guys's
comments now Quinn I love your creepy in
depth of Song of Ice and Fire videos I'd
love to fall asleep to you have it's not
I love to fall asleep - you have
top-notch work thank you so much thank
you so much wavern Stone says you're
encyclopedia acknowledged encyclopedic
knowledge of the Doudna verse is quite
impressive it's nice to know someone
that likes Frank Herbert's work as much
as I do
be well dude yeah I loved you and doing
is something dude is not something that
I read when I was a teenager I picked up
doing a few years ago I started getting
into dune and I thought wow this is one
of the most expansive most philosophical
deepest most amazing science fiction
series that are read and you know making
videos really came out of me talking to
my friends to death about dune and them
kind of rolling their eyes and being
like what I don't understand
and I wanted a way to transmit Doon to a
wider audience and make it more
accessible and that's why I kind of came
out with the ultimate guide to do and
what do you know what works somehow it
worked in in some way thank you so much
for your super chat Don hein
thank you so much do I think they will
do Duncan justice this time around
you mean in comparison to the David
Lynch tune and in the miniseries doom I
hope so
Jason Momoa is playing Duncan as we all
know in the newer in the new doom movies
so we'll see how that works out I don't
know Jason Momoa could be good it could
be bad uh it just all depends it all
depends ok there's there's so much that
could go wrong that it's almost it's
it's difficult to say it's difficult to
say the David Lynch movie I am planning
on doing a review to that David Lynch
movie because I do like it I do like the
David Lynch doom but I think there are
some significant problems with that
movie after the after about the first
hour I want to say that movie kind of
falls apart so it's kind of a finish to
that and then the miniseries is more
accurate to the books definitely but
it's very very it's poorly made the the
the CGI isn't great but it was a really
mm so it kind of got a pass on that
costumes definitely aren't great the
acting is a little iffy the actress that
does alia is it's not great she doesn't
understand the role definitely does not
because I funny thing is I was actually
looking at some of the interviews for
the Children of Dune miniseries and
James McAvoy plays late to the second
and he he was a fan of dune his entire
life since he was a teenager and hearing
him talk about Leto was actually great
because I could tell that he actually
really understood the character but then
the actress that played alia I could
tell that she didn't really get alia and
it kind of you kind of see that in her
portrayal of the character so it's kind
of like
yeah dad so so yeah so yeah but yeah I
have seen I have seen all the movies and
miniseries though but it's not like can
you recommend a great introduction book
into the dune universe well the the only
introduction book into the dune universe
is dune the original dune by Frank
Herbert you have to start with dune that
that's where you have to start you start
with dune and then you you take yourself
where you want to go from there I some
of the great house books the Brian
Herbert ones are okay all right so like
house Karina House Atreides those are
decent and then you don't want to read
sandworms and hunters until after you've
finished the main series I have anyway
but San where's Anne and they're how I
put it I don't want to trash Brian her
because I don't think sand worms and
Hunter are like oh these are the worst
books I've ever written in my read in my
life and just set them on fire and burn
them
I never happened or existed like stomp
on them dump them into the ground and
like no I'm not like that but I don't
think they necessarily follow Frank
Herbert's vision necessarily but I don't
think they're awful but I could I
definitely see why a lot of people are
disappointed with them I definitely
understand that and you know my it
doesn't really it gives you a conclusion
but you might not like the conclusion
and personally it does kind of leave you
one thing it's kind of like yeah and
that's it it's kind of like kind of
fizzles out compared to what Frank Hurd
was set up so that's the only trouble
with those books in my opinion but okay
Lucy Lestat thank you so much for your
super chat um you didn't have a question
but thank you so much for your to super
chat the support is greatly appreciated
greatly appreciated ah P P Lipa
you say my mother would be better it's
still very well you know we got we got
Javier Bardem the stalker so he's I
can't think of a better still guarded
Javier Bardem I'm like already seeing
him as stole gar already seeing him what
were you seeing him still very uh it'll
be exciting it seems like it seems like
everyone's excited I did see that Josh
Brolin video like I said earlier where
he's on a rack isn't he seems Josh
Brolin seems like he's really excited
for this role he seems like he's really
into it which is great we definitely
want actors that are into it I still I
think I'm most nervous about
Shawny who's being portrayed by zendaya
and also Jessa MOA they'll say that
you'll most those are the two that I'm
most kind of fearful of because no
Charlie Shawnee kind of needs to be this
awesome doesn't take no BS Fremen badass
so as I mean I hope zendaya I don't want
to judge a book by its cover but she
just kind of looks like the pretty girl
that's just like guys just like I'm
pretty and I hope that's I hope that
Shaunie has a more of a role to play
Indian in that but you know whatever
and always like Shawnee isn't like my
favorite care of tree in the Dune books
anyways but still like she I don't know
if zendaya is necessarily the best
choice to portray the character that is
in the book you know I mean but I don't
want to hate on it yet I want to hate on
it yet you know and hate on it we can
hate on it after it comes out well I'm
not I'm not planning hidden I'm hoping
that we can I'm hoping that the books
good and on really we're really putting
a lot of our trust in denis villeneuve
who is i've liked a lot of his films I
really love arrival Blade Runner
20:49 was an excellent film regardless
of what some people say some people hate
on it but I really like a rifle and
Blade Runner did not like Sicario I'm
sorry I know a lot of you were big fans
of thin evil knows Sicario movie I was
not into it it was it stressed me out it
was like not the deal for me it was just
like not what I need it I couldn't
relate to anybody
like a goddamned gave me night that that
kind of movie gives me like stress and
[ __ ] gives me panic attacks I can't
handle that
but it's interesting that then the
neither love can go from a movie like
arrival to Sicario and back and forth
totally different tones totally
different types of films and he's
effective in both of them because I know
that even though Sicario was it for me
I'm not saying that it wasn't a
well-crafted movie yeah I mean it was
very well crafted movie that's part of
the reason why it wasn't for me it was
too well crafted and I'm just like uh I
can't watch this too intense for me um
well George our Martin doctor books say
it's who writes the dream of spring well
I don't I don't think it's it's it's
fair to be questioning whether or not
George or Martha's gonna live or die
atif or he finishes his books you know
what I mean just let him do what he
wants to do and let's not let's not
dwell on any of that you know what I
means let's not dwell on who lives and
who dies you know the world is sad
enough you know but thank you for your
super chat dot dot dot
reven Darth Revan what what point do you
think Frank Kurt was trying to make with
the reader constantly by reincarnating
duncan well well that's an interesting
question too in some ways I think that
Duncan could just be in a lot of ways I
feel like Duncan is kind of in a way he
is the reader almost in some way in in
certain novels not necessarily each one
but I think in the same way that Duncan
is kind of dropped into the universe of
the god Emperor with like no knowledge
he's kind of dropped into it and it's
just here that's how the reader is kind
of just dropped into the universe right
God Emperor just starts and it's just
like oh [ __ ] fifteen hundred years later
in this guy's a rule in the Empire
what's going on and it's kind of like
you're in the same perspective as Duncan
and and similarly inherit except doing
it's kind of like oh now it's another
fifteen hundred years later and would
drop into this universe of skiing
vintage as if any Jesuit which is who do
we try
but yeah Oh Marvin Martin great question
what was the bidding just read original
plan for Humanity
if Jessica had obeyed would in the
golden path necessitate the quiz its
head erect doing what he did anyway
that's an interesting point to bring up
because even Leto says to the bidding
gesture and his message and heretics of
June why did you not create the Golden
Path you saw the necessity of it well
from what I can surmise from the Binney
gesture original plan it was it would
have been something similar but
ultimately I think Leto saw some flaw in
the vini Jesuit plan but it would it
would have been ultimately that they
would you create the quiz that's how to
rack they would imprint him in whatever
ways that they do and they would use him
use his power to steer humankind on some
kind of path now the the actual details
of what it would have been aren't
exactly cleaner or at least I can't
really see exactly what they were doing
but I would I wouldn't deny that it
would have been something similar to
what late till ii had to what later ii
did write but ultimately i think the
late i think he did see a flaw and their
whole thing and so i think i think that
he probably did change their design in a
lot of key ways essentially because yeah
ultimately the bene Jesuit design was to
save humanity from ultimately ending it
was to steal humankind on a path that
would lead to their ultimate salvation
so it was essentially their own kind of
golden path but you know it's
interesting I wonder what what because I
know in Children of Dune I think he late
till mentions that there were that there
was a flaw in their entire plan and I
can't recall exactly what he says right
now but he does bring up the fact that
they were flawed in some way but
ultimately ultimately their design would
have been similar is basically down what
I'm getting to
rambling around the question a little
bit but
yeah I hope that answers VT 3100 8 what
is a character that she would like to
meet well obviously the God in fur right
can you imagine talking to the god infer
that immense weight of wisdom and
knowledge knowledge of the past
knowledge of the future there'd be so
much so many questions so much to ask
III I'd ask him about the origins of
life in in in chapter house of doing Oh
trade mentions that the bane of geser
have memories that stretch back to the
origins of life so I can only imagine
that the God in / it does and I'm pretty
sure in that book he does say something
like the terrible ancestry before
consciousness and the in that in that
time I think he mentioned something like
a time between consciousness and non
consciousness or something like that
that a terrible time he even has
memories back to that point like when
consciousness wasn't even when
consciousness was emerging when
consciousness wasn't finite because God
can you imagine that's that's a concept
that's kind of hard to grasp right a
between state between consciousness and
non consciousness is there even such a
thing and what what is that but that day
I think I think there'll be a lot of
interesting things to ask of the Godhead
for I can that be one of them for me so
I definitely want to talk to the god
Emperor
could they ever have perceived the
golden path without going to the place
they dared not go yes and that almost
intrinsic to the quiz that's had Iraq
hmm that's a good point I don't know I
don't see maybe maybe that was part of
their flaw maybe that maybe because they
could not look into that place where the
quiz etc could they would never be able
to fully see where to leave the gold
bath which is why they was which is why
they needed him I think a quiz that sat
interact to kind of help them plot the
golden path and to help them plot their
plans for Humanity and to help lead them
along that path but the problem was see
their ultimate their their flaw was
thinking that they could control
something like that thinking that they
control someone that had that knowledge
of the future in the past that could
look into a place where they couldn't
and had knowledge that they didn't
knowledge is power
that is a cliche but knowledge is power
they he he had he by virtue of them
creating him he had power over them
necessarily so their ultimate mistake
was thinking that they could control
that I think the large difference
between the mini Jesuit and Leto says ah
really
eeeh Aria says that late to the second
he says okay let me start over
I think that a large difference between
the Binnie Jesuit and late to the second
is probably that the vintages are too
cautious and are too quick to seek to
earn are too quick to seek control while
Leto sees absolute control as illusory
okay yeah
was a good point I'll uh good point yeah
I mean yeah yeah yeah I think I mostly
agree with that uh I doubt that most
people oh yeah we were in stone that's a
good point
so we were and someone just said I doubt
that most people could even understand
what Leto was saying to them until much
later in their lives late til eight
lessons for the person and the people
yeah so that's the thing about Leto III
that's the thing like I I imagine having
a conversation with Leto would be you go
to him he says something to you and
you're left going what but the thing
that he said to you probably like
planted seeds and your subconscious that
will sprout at some distant future point
in your life and it will affect you in
profound ways that you could have never
seen before and dads and that would just
be the power of this like grand almost
divine force right so so yeah I can I
can only imagine what it would have been
like to talk to Leto the second and I
think I think the next best thing would
have been Frank Herbert apparently
speaking to him was like he was a great
orator and I've listened to the the the
the few recorded speeches that he has on
interviews on speeches that he has on
YouTube
there's a very interesting one where
he's speaking at college I took some
clips from it from one of my videos and
there was a very interesting guy this
was in the 80s I think and the guy was
very angry he was not seeing Frank
Herbert the question he brings up the
bear and the betrayal of the Baron and
dune which is something that I've been
asked about as well the Buried sexuality
and the guy was very upset and he was
saying that Frank Herbert was that it
was irresponsible of Frank Herbert to
betray the Baron as a gay guy and have
that be the only representation of a gay
guy in the book I don't necessarily see
it that way
I kind of view it as like it's not is
not necessarily he's a homosexual it's
like look at this
extreme insane decadence right that's
thought that's the idea he's he's
grossly overweight because he's
extremely decadent in fact he's got and
it's it's like he takes too much it's
it's it's glutton it's like it's a
horrifying gluttony right that's that's
that's the deal behind the bear and
that's the point of it you know and you
know and it's very easy to like I guess
kind of see through that especially in
this modern political climate but I
thought that was interesting considering
that it was from the 80s it was like 85
I think when he did that interview so
it's kind of interesting that that was
even that was something that someone
brought up then yeah he's exactly
bragger he's a decadent pedo monster
like I don't think ever reading the book
that I saw I don't think I ever really
thought of the Baron has even gay right
I thought of him I was just like a sick
monstrous pedophile right that's that's
that's the way I thought of him so
that's that's and that's an interesting
thing about an interesting thing about
perceptions too I think for some it all
depends on where you are in life and the
lens that you view things to it's all
about perception you know the way you
see it yes yes Brian Wynn and Brenna
said Brendan just said the beto was
overweight because Vanessa take and STD
given to him when he conceived Jessica
and that is a tidbit from the Brian
Herbert work so I don't want to spoil it
if you haven't read it but like that
that's an interesting bit and I like
that it's one of the ideas that I like
it like to be a Jesuit because the Baron
they kind they needed his DNA right but
like because he was such an [ __ ]
about it they gave him this disease that
made him like fat and gross so that
that's that's the deal in the Brian
Herbert books but I know some people
have a problem with whether or not
that's canon or not so that's to deal
with that all right so I want to talk
about heretics of doing a little bit
more so in inherit to subdue and we also
another
group of people that we see a little bit
more closely are the Thule laksa and
it's interesting because that's laylax
ooh mitts laylax ooh are kind of almost
an alien race right it's all because
they're so they love their actual ice
little isolationism they love their
xenophobia so they and not just not just
physically but it's also genetically so
you have like the Masters who are like
they've got like pointy ears and sharp
teeth and like little claws and they
look like little elves right and that's
because they're so genetically isolated
and it's interesting to see their
culture right out the front cuz people
always say oh there are no aliens in the
Dune universe but I'm like the tracks
are kind of the closest thing to aliens
that we're gonna get the plural x2 and I
guess the guild navigators perhaps even
though they're both technically human
they can breed with anyone else but the
deluxe ooh they're an interesting Bunch
they're an interesting Bunch
so in heretics is doing it's revealed
that or at least the sleigh lacks ood
don't see themselves as as bad as
everyone else sees them
and from Wolf's perspective they've been
actively trying to kind of make
themselves be viewed as bad or at least
that's what they tell themselves that's
what they tell themselves right they
tell themselves that we're not as bad as
they view us as and we're just trying to
make them think we're bad even though
their actions kind of even their
internal actions from within
whops own mind he's very willing to kill
to get what they want so they it's very
it's very obvious that they are kind of
immoral hypocrites even though they see
themselves as these kind of like pious
beings that are above everyone else but
and like when from inside WAAFs mind you
can very clearly see that he kind of
only cares about himself and that he is
willing to kill to get what he wants and
he's not and that they are kind of just
as despicable as them as they've ever as
the way the universe saw them they are
really that despicable the female
collects who have not been seen because
they are all clones well yeah spoiler
will be mailed to lilacs ooh they are
the axolotl tanks so at some point
influx of history women able decided
that women you know we don't need you
anymore and it's like we're gonna we're
gonna turn all these women into
basically breeding tanks they're just
basically female Duncan describes when
he sees a vision of his birth he
describes gross female flesh so you can
only like imagine just kind of mutated
women hooked up to machines and their
sole purpose is to produce whatever
those lilacs you want them to produce
and I would wonder how in its centrist I
wonder how spice is produced from within
an axle oil tank because like I think I
can kind of wrap my head around how
ghola a child is produced from an axle
oil tank but how do you make spice in an
axolotl team that's like really out
there I'd love like some information on
how that's done but that's the thing
about freak her but he doesn't like it's
never really about the technology would
Frank Herbert's always more about the
implications of it kind of it's always
about you know the implications of the
technology what does this mean for
humanity what does this mean for people
and their behavior and society and
culture you know it's not it's never
about how it works right which is what
in the axolotl tanks is something that
we will discuss more on this channel
because in Chapter house in Chapter
houses June the vintage ezarik get their
own axolotl tanks and like I mentioned
earlier it was kind of something that
they were forced to do out of necessity
and it's kind of like something that
they have to reconcile reconcile but
it's pragmatism how many parts do you
think the movie will be well well
definitely the first movie is two parts
from every indication that I've seen the
new dual movie it's two parts so what
I'm thinking is that it's gonna agree
Danika comical girl 19 she she thinks
that it's gonna end
Paul Jessica go into the desert
Jessica drinks the water of life spiced
orgy around that time and I I tell Lea's
born and maybe you know maybe or yeah
around that time so that's that that
seems like where it's gonna end because
in the book it's also like it skips
several years after that point and then
like Ali is like up and running and then
Paul has a kid and then like Paul that's
getting ready to challenge still gar
some thing in that they're gonna do two
parts it's a no it seems like they're
doing two parts it seems like from denis
villeneuve these the every indication is
given that we're gonna do two parts and
that's everything that I've seen has
said two parts so it's not three it's
two but I would they definitely gonna
have to rearrange some things and I
definitely think they're gonna have to
flesh out some of the action a little
bit more because that's it's it's needed
for our cinematic purposes not doing
isn't necessarily lacking in action it's
just that the action is behind the
scenes it takes a backseat to the
philosophy and you don't see all the
other stuff that's going on so the plans
within plans and all the plots and stuff
like that so it takes a backseat but
it's it's there it's there do Messiah
could definitely be done with one movie
but honestly I could I could see them
combining dune and children combining
Messiah and Children of Dune and I don't
know if that would necessarily be the
best move because there's such a big
jump in time but do Messiah is not
really it's such a weird little story
right it's not really a typical like
kind of narrative so it dune Messiah
I feel like they'd have a really
difficult time translating that into a
novel write novel not novel trench
translating that novel into into a book
right right what am i I can't talk I
literally just said translating that
novel into a book translating that novel
into a movie
I feel like they'd have a more
difficult time translating do Messiah
than dune even though dune is bigger and
has more going on
just because Steve Messiah doesn't
necessarily follow like a normal
narrative structure it's like our hero
in the end walks out into the desert and
dies I don't think that's necessarily a
set it will be a satisfying ending for
like most movie goers but yeah we'll see
it depends on it depends on who's doing
it though and depends on how how well
but some but it depends on how much they
change some stuff has to be changed I I
think some stuff needs to be added mixed
around moved around you know it's not
it's not like I'm expecting the book on
screen because that's literally
impossible Leto did not have the right
to alter human genetics the way he did
oh so you're using acciona argument are
you so that's interesting question about
rights because it says it's such an
interesting philosophical quandary right
right because what gave lay to that
right you're right he didn't he didn't
but I mean he would say that by the fact
that he is a God the closest thing to
God and man have ever seen that and by
virtue of him seeing further and further
behind than anyone else has that he does
have that right that will be his
argument his argument be like he is the
one that is doing what's necessary to
save humanity
but yeah ultimately ultimately I would
agree with you he didn't have the right
and I think ultimately he might actually
end up agreeing with you maybe he didn't
have the right and maybe that's the
point maybe he's trying to make us see
that he doesn't have the right no one
has that right and he and maybe he's
trying to make sure that you see maybe
he's trying to make sure that you never
ever ever give anyone that right which
we should never do wish you never did we
should always question our leaders we
should always question our leaders and
you know even in the real world
definitely definitely definitely in the
real world see that's the thing that
people don't get about tune to is that
it's it's not just no it's not just
space switches and
guild navigators and quiz that's how to
acts in the sandworms
you know if it's a reflection of our own
society in our own cultures and our own
people it's a reflection of humanity
it's a warning and a lesson to humanity
and yes it is fiction but we can find
the kernels of truth within this fiction
and find the meaningful bits and find
ways to take those kernels of truth out
into the real world and steer our settle
was on a better path you know that's
what Frank curve was trying to teach us
and I and I and I think it's a very
valuable lesson because a lot of times
people fall in love with leaders right
and it's almost like that leader can do
no wrong yeah you fall in love with that
leader and the moment anyone says
anything that's in opposition to that
person that leader that you put up on
this pedestal pedestal you revolt and
it's because you're worshipping this
leader as almost as as a god which you
shouldn't you should always question
your leaders you should always question
your charismatic leader no matter what
no matter how good their record is no
matter the the the platitudes and nice
things that they say and no matter all
of it you should always question them
and I think that's ultimately the point
yes yes bright glory we have to see
through the cult of personality yeah you
know that's a very important thing with
politics and I'm not I'm not gonna get
political but I'm just saying no matter
what side of the political spectrum that
you're on I feel like you should always
you should never just take what a
politician says he was at face value you
should look at what they've done in the
past look at what they said in the past
look at what they're doing now and just
really really really questioned them and
you know at the crux of it Frank Herbert
was in the political system he wrote
speeches for politicians literally so he
was in there he understood how it works
and so he put a lot of his knowledge
from being around politicians and being
in Washington he put all that knowledge
into dune and he said you know what I'm
gonna show you how what
works I'm gonna show you how it really
goes down I'm gonna show you why you
really can't trust what these people are
saying most of the time it's like
Aaliyah and children of the dune she's
possessed by the Baron she's literally
possessed by the Baron trying to destroy
trying to destroy allspice on Arrakis
and it's like even though that's
ultimately what late to the second date
but but you know that's not the point
well yeah question leaders that's the
main point of the story that's that but
it's the crux of it the whole main issue
mm-hmm
Michael um crew I can't say your last
name I'm so sorry
but Michael says I believe the saying
goes fiction is a social commentary of
our existence and I definitely agree
with that statement it definitely is
really at least good fiction is the
social commentary of our existence
all right that's why I think I am bored
by a lot of a lot of things that are
some people are interested in a lot of
the really popular like movies and stuff
because it's just like what is what is
this teaching me what is this saying
about us and humankind and the human
condition what is this really saying
like I feel like if you're gonna make a
piece of Arts a movie or book or you're
gonna write a book your goal shouldn't
just be entered to entertain but to
teach and and and you should you should
write about the human struggle that's
the only thing that's worth writing
about your writing should reflect us at
least at least that's what I think and
and I I'm not super into the stuff this
is like Avengers in game not not saying
that that I don't enjoy like the Marvel
stuff but I'm just like everyone's
obsessed with those movies movies and
I'm just like yeah but it's just kind of
kind of hollow at the end of the day
it's kind of I mean I guess I guess
their nose kind of has a philosophy kind
of like balance and whatever yada yada
yada but it's kind of a it's kind of
vague when you get down to it and it's
kind of also been there done that when
you get down to it so it's like yeah
really saying and out of all the Marvel
movies I feel like probably Captain
America Winter Soldier kind of that was
the one that I was like wow that one did
a really good job of actually saying
something important right like that was
the one that was like it actually had a
lot to say about like government
surveillance and like privacy and stuff
like that so I was really into that one
but then most of them are just I'm just
kind of like say something and say
something mean let's say something to me
and I feel the same way about you know
Star Wars or like a lot of the other
really popular stuff you know that's why
I was really excited that Villeneuve is
the one that's doing dune because I had
seen a rival and a rival was just like
oh my god he was everything that I love
about science fiction ever since like I
fell in love with Star Trek and card and
like The Twilight Zone and like every is
everything that I love about science
fiction because it was mystery and it
was it was it was telling us something
about humankind and human nature and he
was to ever see it was just like it was
it was unique it was different it was
just like ah that's what we need that's
what the world needs and I feel like
dune is great right now because dune is
a series that totally subverts like just
the typical ideas of like how a story is
told and it like totally subverts well
the first book it hooks you in and then
the rest of the book the rest of the
series is made to totally subvert
everything that you've been taught and
teach you that the [ __ ] aid it the first
book introduces you to the illusion and
the and the rest of them teach you to
see through the illusion that's how I
would describe them it teaches you to
see through the illusion and to see how
it really goes down so Marvin Marvin you
are so generous thank you so much for
your super chat what was Frank Herbert's
point with preborn alia anti-aging is a
sign of possession but in thousands of
years there would surely have been other
secret immortals for no reason than
simple human nature
okay so that seems like a multi-faceted
question I don't know if if at least
okay so in children of June right Lea's
anti-ageing wasn't necessarily a sign of
possession right it was a sign that she
really didn't have any respect for the
beanie Jesuit tenants like it would I
get what I guess as a virtue of that
that could kind of be a sign of
possession or could or she's kind of I
don't know but it's I don't think the
fact that she was doing that is
necessarily a sign of possession because
if you remember in God improv tune
that's what the the average vintage
Ezard are doing right there they're
doing that because like they don't have
access to spice so they're kind of like
doing it to themselves so they can live
longer so it's not necessarily sign of
possession but on the point of wouldn't
they're sure they have been other secret
immortals for no other reason than
simple human nature I'm not quite sure I
understand what you mean right
not ownership I'm not quite sure I
understand what you mean so so alia was
keeping herself young by virtue of Bene
Gesserit prana Bindu skills which
allowed them to just kind of rearrange
their inner workings and she can just
kind of maintain that youthfulness in a
way that the average person never could
which didn't really relate back to her
being pre born necessarily so if you
could just clarify that I will be happy
to answer it
okay okay okay okay
Carson Carson golden says I think Duncan
Idaho is the most tortured character in
the book I think for sure I think for
sure and I think we do see that - what
when Duncan when his memories are
reawakened and he sees himself die over
and over and over again cuz that's the
thing he remembers that so as far as he
concerned that happened to him so yeah
but ultimately I think Duncan Duncan but
later later the second as well III feel
like there can
Tinder's later the second is is is is
very tortured as well because because
it's like to live 4000 years and then
never have sex so that that's when they
like they never feel the touch of
another person right I mean that's
that's that that's the stuff that's
that's that's some tough that's some
tough stuff right it's like from the
time he's a child it's just like now I'm
locked into this this path and it's like
it's not it's not just that he's can't
touch another person it's like he can
see the path he can see it clearly so
it's like poor him oh just infinite
boredom and then yes so that all there
really is to do is to like lapse back
into his other memories so yeah later
later when Duncan I feel like they kind
of share they share the role of probably
most to conflict a character not
complete the character by most tortured
character
hmm yeah that's a good point
Aram rixel good point about the Brian
Herbert ending thank you so much Kyle
elder thank you so much for your kind
comments okay oh that's a good question
Tracy Bolden Tracy Bolden says I never
really understood how alia could have
the Baron in her head as she is female
could she have both lines of her
heritage well you see this is a this is
kind of a misunderstanding and doing I
think it's kind of it's a little bit
Frank Herbert's fault because of some of
the wording in the earlier dune book but
it's it's kind of more understood in the
later dune books basically the way other
memory works is that it's not
necessarily that you don't have access
to your male ancestors it's that you
don't have access to your paternal
memories so she cooks she can't see Leto
the second she can't see Latos memories
not like to us she can't she can't see
her father the do plato's memories she
can't see his mother's memory she can't
see his grandmother's memories she can't
see his grandfather's memories but she
can see Latos she can see Jessica's
father's memories the Barons mother's
memories the bay so it's like she can
see the maternal side not necessarily
the paternal side so a deed so that does
that make sense so it's not necessarily
that they can't see the male ancestors
they can't look into the paternal side
so yeah well that's that's actually
clarified in the later books a little
bit more and then so that's a question
that a lot of people bring up because
it's not exactly clear early on it's not
exactly yeah it's not exactly super
clear early on but Frank does flesh it
out flesh it out as the books continue
as an author and a retired teacher says
Augustus 87 Harun as an author and a
retired teacher I just wanted to express
my appreciation for your love of a good
story your ability to point out
interesting
of this beloved work brings me much joy
thank you so much for your kind words
thank you guys so much for your support
and joining me on the strength day it's
been great
I'm if you've been enjoying the stream
so far please feel free to leave a like
it really really helps out with the
streams because it makes it easier for
people to see the streams later on
because YouTube always does weird stuff
from streams like it'll kind of hide for
a little bit so by you guys liking it
here
it really helps a channel out and it
really helps the video be seen later on
you know form re-watch ability purposes
and whatnot yes yes indeed murder the
like button yes yes yes yes yes so yeah
so um yeah I wanted to talk about a
little bit before I go here I wanted to
talk about just like some of the
technical stuff that went into my
ultimate guide to heretics of June so
that just went up about five days ago
and so far it's my favorite episode that
I've done so far just because of the way
that I was able to do things with the
editing that I wasn't able to do in the
other episodes and I feel like it looks
aesthetically better than any other
episode that I've done so far
so the first episode that I ever did the
part one the introduction that was like
one of the biggest projects that I had
ever done at the time and I thought that
was difficult but even though when
there's like some mistakes in it there's
obvious mistakes in pronunciation there
are some mistakes in the text and I was
kind of new to some of the effects that
I was using and you know and so that one
that one I still like that video a lot
and then the second one the the one
that's just doomed the first dune book
that one was I went less on the visuals
and more just kind of like on breaking
down the story so that one that one that
one is kind of I guess I would call that
one the
least impressive as far as the editing
and then we have the Dumas Iowa which is
kind of my least favorite one and not
because it's added poorly but just
because I go back and I look at my dune
Messiah ultimate guide and I feel like I
could have done more exposition I just
like go into that one or just like oh I
could have said this here and I could
have done that there so that one's like
uh if he but I really like the way
edited it in the way I had like the the
characters faces showing up and like I
kind of I thought I was kind of putting
you in the scene I really like the way I
did that so I did transfer that element
over to the Children of Dune video which
personally I feel like is the most
underrated of the ultimate guy at Circus
that one I feel like I I that one was
the Children of Dune ultimate guide that
I did that was the closest video to my
original design up until that point to
what I originally had wanted to do with
this series as far as like making it
look nice and adding editing it really
well and just laid that was like the
closest to my original design and then
when God Emperor came out I couldn't do
because I was planning on like really
going in with God in fur and doing a lot
of like really fancy pantsy editing
stuff but at the time that I was editing
it my computer was dying like my mic my
desktop was dying and like my desktop
was about four or five years old at that
point and it was just like not having it
anymore and it was the biggest project
that I ever donned an hour and 40
minutes long it kept crashing and I was
like I just cannot do all the stuff that
I actually want to put in this episode
and I can't have all these different
layers because it's gonna significantly
slow down the process and my computer's
gonna keep crashing so I had to make
some sacrifices with that episode but I
made sure that the narration was really
good and that the text was really good
and that I did the right amount of
exposition but with heretics I was so
excited because I got a brand-new
computer last year and I was able to
really really edit the heck out of this
one and I was at I was able to put like
how the phases coming up and I was able
to have like moving backgrounds and
multi layers and make it seem
multi-dimensional
and like really illustrate when they
were on different places I really wanted
to give gamoo a certain look and I
really wanted to give a rack as a
certain look so when I cut scenes that
you would know exactly where I was you
would know that this is camo
this is chapter house this is Rakus so I
feel like I was able to do so many
things in heretic subdued that I wasn't
able to do before and I'm very proud of
it and I hope you all check it out if
you haven't yet and yeah it is it is
very exciting it's very exciting to get
it out and with very excited to get see
everyone's reaction I'm so happy that
you guys have really liked it I'm so
happy that you guys really love my doing
content it's it's been such a blessing
it's been such so great to come on here
and be able to talk about doing you guys
have no idea how much of a wonderful
outlet this has been for me to just to
express my love just for like nerdy
science fiction and nerdy fantasy and
yeah and I hope you guys continue to
stay subscribed and of course a crap ton
more dune content coming in the future
as always and even more stuff coming
this year like Hyperion I've got some
Hyperion videos coming out by Dan
Simmons have got more foundation stuff
coming up we've got some Wheel of Time
comparison videos coming up in the
future where we're going to be comparing
the Benny jezzer it to the to the I sad
I from the Wheel of Time who I feel are
based on the VHS right so a lot of
interesting things coming up for you
guys and in the future so it's just been
great and yeah that's what I want to say
got another super chat from you Marvin
Mar and dude you are loaded don't have
you think about they thank you so much
for the super chat you guys have no idea
how much this helps I mean what is Frank
Herbert trying to say I was waiting on
you I mean what is record we're trying
to say with pre-birth and indefinite
life is too big a temptation for any
doctrine but it's alia the only one BS
well when it comes to pre-birth it's not
know okay see my interpretation of it
the reason that alia succumbed to
possession was it was due to the fact
that she a child who possessed no real
self him no real individuality had other
identities forced upon her which clouded
her own awareness her own sense of self
and she succumbed to the sea of other
presences and I don't think Georgia
Martin is making a statement about I
don't think he's making a statement
about like the will about necessarily
we'll all right it's it's Franco it was
trying to say with rebirth and
indefinite life is too big a temptation
for any doctrine but also Lee Elia is
the only one I don't think see I don't
think alia succumb to possession due to
the fact that she was tempted for and
she was tempted to have an eternal life
or she was tempted to have any to
indefinite life that wasn't the reason
she succumbed to possession she
succumbed to possession because she
didn't she couldn't maintain her own
individuality in the sea of other
consciousnesses and I think this is due
in some part because of the fact that
Jessica abandoned her on a rack is and
in help and are the reason that and
larger the reason that late to the
second and gain EEMA were able to
overcome the possession was because of
the fact that they had each other they
were able to rely on each other with
wasps alia she had no one and when and
in the instances where she had no one
the Baron saw an opportunity that that
ego inside of her stepped forward and
said I will help you I don't I don't
think I don't think she was possessed
because of the out of a temptation to
extend her life is what I'm saying if
Vinny does were don't love why care
about humanity good point
and that's kind of the point of that's
kind of the point of heretics isn't it
well that's kind of the point that that
old raid come that's kind of the
understanding that she comes to in the
end of heretics so in the beginning
you're presented with this with from old
raids perspective she's saying that the
Binney gesture do not love we've been
taught not to love remember that woman's
pain yada yada yada but in the end of it
what does she say she says to Duncan I
feel what I feel noble purpose Leto said
to them what is what is life what is
survival if you no longer hear the music
of life if you're no longer called to
noble purpose and I think I think that
in the end Oh trade saw through that and
she saw that you know maybe love is
crippling but they can't suppress it and
I think she saw that she couldn't
suppress it and the vini Jesuit
shouldn't suppress it so that's that's
my own personal interpretation and I
know that some of you might have some
different interpretations of that but
that's the way I interpreted it
forget possession I'm asking why alia is
the only one who goes for immortality
well she's not she's not hot you're
alone as well your lawn does it as well
and Children of Dune Jessie not yeah
yeah yeah your lawn does it as well it's
a yeah eerily lawn is doing yeah I think
you mean what what is Frank Herbert
trying to say about possession about pre
birth in a broader spectrum is what I
think you mean and yeah and but to
answer your other part of the question
to UM alia is not necessarily beholden
to Binney jazzer at tennis right so
she's kind of heretical in that way
right so she kind of doesn't care the
the been a Jesuit seem greatly
conditioned against this but they are
told early on like that this little
destroy us like doing this will lead to
our destruction and when it comes to
alia I don't think she really cares I
think she's just kind of like whatever I
don't care I'm not I'm not have any
Jesuit and so I think that's her whole
deal and so and when it comes to
pre-birth you're asking me what what
does it mean I guess in the broader
theme of what Frank Herbert is trying to
say let me think let me think we think
okay it could be a statement on
individuality and need to be a person
before you offer up in other entities
into yourself because you you have like
normal Reverend mothers who go through
immense amount of training and ment
amount of training and and and they have
they have to hone their skills
significantly before they can undergo
the spice agony and bring these other
presences into themselves and alia being
pre born she kind of or anyone being pre
born it's kind of like it's kind of like
what is what is what is self when when
you're born with other memories right
what are you really
like a lot what are you but a
conglomeration of a bunch of other
things uh I mean I think it's it's it's
it's kind of amazing that alia had any
kind of personality considering the fact
that she was born with other Minds
living inside of herself right so I feel
like it could be a statement on alia
Leah's whole struggle it's kind of a
statement on individuality in being
trapped by your past and it's a
difficult subject to tackle I don't want
to I don't want to ramble on it because
I don't I don't know if I don't know if
I actually have a clear answer I don't
know if I can actually clearly answer
this question it's a very difficult one
because you're asking me about like
broader theme and the idea of of
pre-birth as a whole is something that I
need to like actually contemplate for
hours before I can actually definitively
say or definitively definitively give
you a conclusion on what I think Frank
Herbert was meaning here oh I don't feel
like I'm giving a really great answer
but yeah yeah James James bras I like
what you just said pre-birth you must
know yourself after all tea will have no
identity therefore the pre got preborn
will succumb to possession yeah that's
kind of what I'm trying to say right
yeah that's kind of I'm trying to say I
don't want to sound like an idiot here
Norma was something else entirely
alright guys so yeah I'm glad we had
this talk I'm glad we had this talk
alright so thank you Thank You Marvin
Martin I hope I answer your question to
some extent we can talk about this more
if you have a Twitter feel free to
message me on Twitter and we can kind of
like we can go back and forth on Twitter
we can maybe figure this out you and me
because I think that's a very
interesting concept and interesting idea
to think about like what what what is he
trying to say in a broader scale yeah
but thank you guys so much for joining
in joining in with me
and listening to me talk about dune it's
been great I love you guys you guys are
always supportive like the stream and
subscribe if you're not already
subscribed it's been a pleasure thank
you guys so much peace out